En pleno Himalaya, Nepal es uno
de los países más aislados, remotos y pobres
del mundo. Tradicionalmente ha sido una especie
de “protectorado”, de país satélite
de la India. Sin embargo, a finales de 2017,
el Partido Comunista de Nepal obtuvo una victoria
aplastante en las elecciones y ahora ha puesto
sus ojos en Pekín. En este vídeo te contamos
que está ocurriendo y también cual es el
gran tesoro oculto de este país. Vamos allá.
Amigos, os hago una pregunta y no vale buscarla
en Google, ¿sabéis en qué país nació
Buda? Un, dos, tres….
¡Exacto! En Nepal, un país situado en pleno
Himalaya y que es el hogar de muchas de las
montañas más altas de todo el mundo.
En concreto, en este país, que tiene una
superficie similar a la de Nicaragua, podemos
encontrar 8 de las 14 cumbres con más de
8000 metros que hay en el mundo, incluido,
por supuesto el Everest.
Y no solo eso… en total hay 240 picos con
más de 6.000 metros.
Vamos, en otras palabras, Nepal es todo un
paraíso para los amantes de la montaña.
Y por cierto, Katmandú, su capital, la capital
del Himalaya, es también una de las ciudades
más queridas por los mochileros de todo el
mundo , ¿por qué?
(Pues tal vez tenga algo que ver que esta
sea una ciudad de templos, pagodas y callejuelas
llenas de vida. Una capital donde, en pleno
siglo XXI, no vais a poder encontrar rascacielos,
ni avenidas anchas, ni autobuses modernos
ni prácticamente ninguna franquicia de lujo.)
Suena bien, ¿verdad? Algo así como un último
resquicio de la historia en los tiempos modernos.
Desgraciadamente, amigos, Nepal también es
uno de los países más pobres del mundo.
Según Naciones Unidas, Nepal es uno de los
países de Asia que peor puntúa en el índice
de Desarrollo Humano…. Bueno, de Asia y
de prácticamente todo el planeta, porque, amigos,
Nepal se sitúa en la posición 144.
Y no es para menos.
Fijaos, a pesar de tener casi 30 millones
de habitantes, su economía es más pequeña
que la de Bolivia, cuya población apenas
supera los 10 millones de habitantes. Es decir,
en términos per cápita Bolivia es un país
3 veces más rico que Nepal.
Por eso, cada día que pasa unos 1.500 jóvenes,
¡1.500 jóvenes! se marchan al extranjero.
Y es que, amigos, los nepalíes no lo han
tenido nada, pero que nada fácil.
¿Queréis saber por qué? Pues… atentos.
UN PAÍS SOMETIDO
Amigos, el sistema político de Nepal ha estado anclado
en el pasado hasta prácticamente antes de
ayer.
Sí, hasta el año 2008 Nepal fue una monarquía
de corte absolutista, bajo el control exclusivo
del rey….
[Y por cierto, como curiosidad: a pesar de
ser la tierra natal del mismísimo Buda, hasta
el 2006 fue el único país d el mundo con
el hinduismo como religión oficial.]
(Pero, no solo eso, entre 1996 y 2006 el país
sufrió una guerra civil entre las fuerzas
del gobierno, las fuerzas de una monarquía-dictadura
y los rebeldes maoístas, partidarios de establecer
una república comunista. )
Tal cual como lo escucháis: monarquía, guerra
civil, maoísmo… sí, creo ahora podemos
entender porque diantres este país es tan
pobre.
El caos ha sido tan grande que en los últimos
30 años, la esperanza media de vida de un
gobierno ha sido de... 1 año.
Pero…,amigos, aquí no termina todo. Nepal
tiene otra característica que ha condicionado
mucho su situación política y también económica.
Veréis, cómo sabéis Nepal no tiene salida
al mar… y además, ¿os habéis dado cuenta
de quienes son sus únicos vecinos?
(Exactamente, Nepal se encuentra entre dos
grandes colosos, entre las que seguro serán
2 de las grandes potencias de este siglo:
la India y China.
Dos países que, además, no se llevan del
todo bien, como ya vimos en VisualPolitik.)
[Sí, creo que podemos decir que China e India
son prácticamente las únicas preocupaciones
serias que tiene el Ministerio de Exteriores
de este país]
Pues bien, el caso es que tradicionalmente,
en buena parte gracias a que la orografía
lo favorece, Nepal ha sido una especie de
país satélite de la India. Algo que el gobierno
de Nueva Delhi siempre ha tenido muy claro.
(“La India quiere microgestionar Nepal.
Tienen que controlar todas las citas del gobierno,
tienen que saberlo todo. Sus embajadores se
comportan como virreyes. Pero, acaso ¿no
somos una nación soberana?” Kishor Shrestha,
director del semanario nepalí, Jana Astha
y miembro de la Junta Directiva del Consejo
de Prensa de Nepal.)
Tal vez la mejor prueba de como la India ha
querido siempre controlar los destinos de
este remoto país, la tuvimos en 2015.
En aquel momento, amigos, las fuerzas políticas
estaban diseñando la nueva Constitución
de la recién creada República Federal Democrática
de Nepal.
Pues bien, Nueva Delhi exigió que Nepal crease
una provincia separada para las personas de
ascendencia india que viven en las llanuras
de Terai, una región en el sur de Nepal,
en la frontera con la India.
Algo a lo que las fuerzas políticas nepalíes
se opusieron con rotundidad: no establecerían
bajo ningún concepto separaciones políticas
en base a la identidad.
Pues bien, cómo Nueva Delhi no obtuvo una
respuesta afirmativa, os hago una pregunta,
¿qué creeis que hizo?
Pues… ni más ni menos que bloquear las
fronteras, no de forma oficial, pero los camiones
con provisiones dejaron de pasar.
Esto sería algo, malo, malísimo, bajo cualquier
circunstancia… pero es que el bloqueo además
se produjo cuando el país peor lo estaba
pasando… poco después de sufrir un enorme
terremoto que causó enormes daños. en Nepal.
(“El terremoto de magnitud 7,8 que sacudió
Nepal el 25 de abril de 2015, además de cobrarse
más de 8.700 vidas y destruir medio millón
de casas, movió la montaña más alta del mundo. BBC)
Y, ¿sabéis qué? Este no ha sido ni el único
bloqueo ni la única estrategia que India
ha utilizado para presionar a los políticos
nepalíes a seguir sus… “¿consejos?”.
Al fin y al cabo, el comercio con la India
ha representado tradicionalmente casi las
tres cuartas partes de todo el comercio de Nepal.
Pero, ahora, tras siglos de monarquía absoluta
y décadas de guerra y caos, Nepal está viendo
cómo las cosas comienzan a normalizarse y
como la democracia se abre paso. Y también
como se abre la puerta de China.
LA LLEGADA DE CHINA
China y Nepal comparten una frontera de 1.400
kilómetros. Y amigos, en los últimos años,
esta frontera se ha puesto de moda.
Las relaciones comerciales entre ambos países
se han multiplicado por 3 desde el año 2010.
Además China se ha convertido en el país
que cada año más dinero invierte en Nepal
y el turismo procedente de la gran potencia
asiática crece como la espuma. Tan solo en
la última década y a pesar del terremoto,
el número de turistas chinos que cada año
llegan a Nepal se ha multiplicado por 4.
(“En la actualidad, las relaciones entre
China y Nepal se están desarrollando al ritmo
más rápido que hemos visto nunca", Yu Hong,
Embajador de China en Nepal.)
Así es como están creciendo las relaciones
entre Nepal y China.
(Con la hidroelectricidad a punto de cimentarse,
los negocios chinos ya están alrededor de
este pequeño país sudasiático. Los proveedores
de internet chinos están rompiendo el monopolio
indio, los turistas chinos están inundando
Nepal, instituciones dedicadas al idioma chino
están creciendo rapidísimo, más estudiantes
nepalíes están viajando a China que a India,
y cientos de altos cargos del gobierno nepalí
son invitados a China cada año como parte
de toda una campaña de adulación sin precedentes.
Pero… ¿sabéis qué? Aun hay más.
.
A finales de 2017 se celebraron elecciones
para elegir un nuevo parlamento y un nuevo
gobierno:
La victoria del Partido Comunista fue aplastante.
Un partido comunista muy pero que muy influenciado
por Pekín.
Ahora el nuevo Primer Ministro, Khadga Prasad
Oli, se ha fijado como prioridad número 1
impulsar las relaciones con su vecino del
norte para hacer crecer el comercio y las
inversiones pero también para ganar independencia
de la India.
Y, amigos, Pekín tiene claro que no va a
desaprovechar esta oportunidad:
por eso ya ha puesto sobre la mesa grandes
proyectos que pueden cambiar para siempre
la situación de Nepal: carreteras, aeropuertos
y sobre todo la promesa de una nueva línea
de ferrocarril.
(El gobierno chino ha hecho público que está
estudiando extender el ferrocarril que conecta
el Tibet con la costa oriental hasta la frontera
con Nepal. Y por supuesto hay pocas dudas
de que China no tendría ningún problema
en financiar la construcción del ferrocarril
hasta Katmandú)
Ojo, porque no hablamos de un proyecto precisamente
pequeño.
Conectar Nepal y China por ferrocarril podría
suponer multiplicar por 10, por 15 o incluso
por 20 la llegada de turistas chinos. Y no
solo eso, si el tren, además, se conectara
con la red de ferrocarril India… podríamos
hablar de una revolución en el tráfico de
mercancías entre los dos grandes colosos.
("Si podemos conectar esta red ferroviaria
a nuestro proyecto ferroviario este-oeste,
podemos revolucionar el comercio China-India,
con Nepal en el medio" Khadga Prasad Oli,
Primer Ministro de Nepal)
A ver, no es que no el nuevo gobierno pretenda
ni mucho menos romper con la India, pero todo
apunta a que Nepal ha dejado de ser un subordinado
de Nueva Delhi. Y lo más importante, por
primera vez parece que este país tiene opciones
claras de lograr un futuro mejor. ¿Queréis
saber cómo? Atentos.
EL FUTURO: AGUA Y MONTAÑAS
Amigos, Nepal es uno de los países más pobres
de todo el mundo… pero no tiene porque seguir
siéndolo. Me explico.
Por un lado, Nepal es un país con naturaleza,
montañas, paisajes exóticos y una gastronomía
impresionante. No es un secreto que su potencial
turístico es enorme, sobre todo si mejoran
los comunicaciones con China, como hemos visto
es muy probable que ocurra.
¿A quien no le gustaría vistar Nepal?
Pero ahí no termina todo… ni mucho menos.
El gran tesoro oculto de Nepal es… el agua.
Tal cual como lo escucháis… ¡el agua!
Veréis, como ya hemos visto Nepal es un país
con montañas enormes y valles escarpados
que han sido horadados por grandes ríos.
De hecho, ríos tan importantes como el Ganges
nacen aquí, en el Himalaya nepalí.
¿Y que se puede hacer con toda esta riqueza
naturaleza natural? Pues…
(Los estudios que ha realizado el gobierno
nepalí muestran que los abundantes recursos
hídricos de Nepal pueden producir enormes
cantidades de energía hidroeléctrica a muy
bajo coste. En concreto la capacidad potencial
de producción eléctrica podría ser de casi
el 50%, la mitad de toda la producción de
los mismísimos Estados Unidos)
Y eso, amigos, es mucha pero que mucha electricidad.
Además, ¿Habéis pensado en otro detalle?
Nepal se encuentra entre India y China, y
muy cerquita de Bangladesh… tres economías
en rápido crecimiento cuyo consumo eléctrico
se está disparando…
Y Nepal puede tener
la capacidad de suministrarles la electricidad
más barata de todas.
Claro que hasta ahora nada de esto sido explotado…
pero todo apunta a que este “abandono”
puede quedar atrás muy rápido. Si el país
recobra la estabilidad los inversores harán
cola para financiar y desarrollar este tipo
de proyectos…
(“El único recurso que tenemos, como los
países árabes tienen con el petróleo, es
el agua”
Chhabi Gaire - director del Proyecto Hidroeléctrico
de Rasuwagadhi, una planta de 111 megavatios
en construcción cerca de la frontera con China.)
Y no solo eso… ¿Habéis pensado que el
acercamiento a China podría lograr que el
dinero chino llegará al país para financiar
grandes proyectos hidroeléctricos?
Pues eso es precisamente en lo que está pensando
el gobierno nepalí.
(“El nuevo primer ministro comunista reiniciará
un proyecto liderado por chinos de 2.500 millones
de dólares que fue retirado por el anterior
gobierno, gobierno que era considerado amistoso
hacia la India”.
En fin, amigos, así están las cosas. Nepal
es un país muy pobre, pero con nuevas políticas
podría dejar de serlo.
Ahora bien, ¿Será el nuevo gobierno capaz
de dejar atrás sus inclinaciones ideológicas
y apostar por la estabilidad, la apertura
y la inversión extranjera? Sólo el tiempo
será capaz de responder a esta pregunta.
Pero ahora turno para tí, ¿Crees que Nepal
debe apostar por China o debe continuar estrechando
lazos con la India?
Déjanos tu respuesta en los comentarios y
también en esta encuesta. Si te ha resultado
interesante el vídeo dale a like y no olvides
suscribirte a VisualPolitik para seguir descubriendo
cosas interesantes que pasan en nuestro mundo.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.